rennes est toujours le sale temps le
rhône déborde et la méditerranée vire au
gris valérie gage et les foudres de la
météo ont frappé toute la france
rarement dans notre pays on aura vu
autant d'eau le rhône a atteint
aujourd'hui un débit de 7 mille mètres
cubes à la seconde un record inégalé
depuis 30 ans au total dans la drôme et
dans l'ardèche près de 600 personnes ont
dû être évacuées
parfois dans l'urgence certains
habitants des zones inondables n'avait
en effet pas respecté les consignes de
sécurité
pourtant largement diffusés ces jours
derniers à celle yeux dans l'isère un
affaissement de terrain a fait dérailler
un convoi de neuf wagons citernes
aucune fuite n'a été constatée mais le
trafic ferroviaire entre lyon et
grenoble ne devrait pas être rétabli
avant dimanche soir tout le nord de
l'isère et ce soir inondé certaines
communes comme saint savin sont privés
d'eau potable et dès ce matin des
assureurs s'étaient regroupés près de
bourgoin pour informer les personnes
sinistrées des démarches à entreprendre
inquiétude aussi ce soir dans les alpes
de haute provence sisteron surveille
d'un oeil attentif la montée du muet ch
depuis hier cet affluent de la durance
est en crue les habitants de la partie
basse de la ville ont été conviés à
quitter provisoirement leur maison le
barrage de serre ponçon situées en amont
de sisteron frôlé sa cote d' alerte si
les pluies reprennent
il faudra certainement ouvrir les vannes
et évacuer les habitants des rives de la
durance